yeah when your ship breaks in half and
you're helplessly floating out there in
the freezing ass ocean one man you want
to save you and that's James T Cook
captain of Starship Enterprise
the finest hours I love how they make
this one plural usually the finest hour
it's like an hour this was like now it's
more than one hour it's plural so the
finest hours is the true story of a ship
that breaks in half its crew is
helplessly out there floating in the
ocean they don't have a lot of time to
have a few hours before they sing Chris
Pines in the Coast Guard so he's ordered
to take a small crew gone through and
assist that ship bring the people back
alive funny because it's just powered
through the entire plot of the movie the
movies like two hours long but it takes
a while to get there first of all I like
Chris Pine Chris Pines a likable dude I
like seeing him get work I'll I've seen
him play a hero he's kind of an underdog
that's what like about Chris Pine and
Casey Affleck in this movie they're both
underdogs in their professions they're
not really well-liked by the people
around them the people they work with
but if there are people who are going to
get them through it they're the ones
because they got the heart this movie
does a really good job at showing scale
like when things are supposed to be big
like that's a big-ass wave if it's big
and look cold and wet like when they're
cool and wet you're like yeah I'm
freezing too and I'm just watching the
thing man I'm in a cozy ass theater but
I feel pretty chilly right now but yeah
the path to getting there is pretty
drawn-out and it takes a while to get
there not that you need to see
excitement and carnage in every shot and
movie like this we saw the trailer we
know what the premise is so when there's
more downtime than not you just feel
like all right let's get to what we came
for but this movie definitely does play
up the fields I mean the odds are
against these guys and when you see the
common man going up against these
astronomical odds and he's a nice dude
you're like I want to root for you
because I completely do root for you
because you are a nice guy wanna see him
succeed that snares you into the movie
that hooks you and now you're in it if
you like the market and kind of botched
a few things in here and that shouldn't
be on the movie but I do have to address
it in this review the trailer really
shows the premise condensed into a
couple minutes and when I was watching
it I was like oh yeah I was just kind of
the entire movie I hate that it's
just it's more and more common which
makes it more and more infuriating and
frustrating and it is a pretty
by-the-numbers rescue movie I mean you
have Casey Affleck then you have the guy
who's completely against much you to
know what you're talking about but you
know Casey Affleck is actually the one
who has the plan will wear
but in the way the movie breaks it down
you've seen it a hundred thousand times
before in film so in the end the finest
hours is really just kind of a fine
couple hours you got a couple good leads
a couple good guys you want to root for
them to fighting the odds they're saving
lives you love that you like the overall
theme of this movie but I feel like
given the fact this movie is pitched in
the promo as the most daring rescue and
Coast Guard history you're like the
movie should have been a little more
interesting but a lot of it is lead up
to Chris Pine leaving and Chris Pine
leaves and it's him taking his boat a
few miles out there and that's the rest
of the movie and then there's that whole
rescue attempt thing you don't get dish
fulls of what you came for but in the
end I will say the finest hours is still
a good time no alcohol required so the
finest hours have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite rescue movie biopic fictional
whatever whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more